Oh papa welcome back to another episode
of South Park yeah boy best gamer on
YouTube mina-san konnichiwa it's me
we're going back into our house and
talking to our parents have you lost
your [ __ ] mind our child felt the
need to go talk to the school counselor
doesn't that bother you at all so you
told him the truth yes
I said we were away all right child's
gender is how we have you dumb [ __ ]
you'll ruin everything I don't have to
listen to this from a stoned out pothead
I need a drink
sure drown your problems in Chardonnay
you stupid skank oh hey hey well I'm
exhausted
gotta get ready for bed dinner's on the
table if you want it Punk
but then straight to bed okay pothead
alcoholic what a nice lovely home to
come home to especially as a
gender-neutral anime queen eat dinner
okay well let's go and have some dinner
boys chicken wings racist joke that is
unfunny what's wrong with me okay
alright I can't eat dinner we're in my
room what the heck oh there it is sorry
that's the face I make when I don't
chick get chicken dinner as well what
even is that
oh my god it's so emotional I guess we
will go back to sleep and think about
how our dad had sex with our mom after
we lose this Jack god damn we got a lot
of loot how low all right let's go to
sleep everybody good night me now son
sweetie I just want you to know that
whatever happens mommy always loved you
good night sweetheart and Sun hasn't
even gone down yet that time that's when
the creeps come out but unfortunately
for the creeps the other thing that
comes out at night hmm
what's gonna happen with the key all
right so we're we're escaping whoa whoa
whoa
that's rare so the game actually told us
that we are a too low level to do this
quest so I might struggle a little bit
but you know I am pro gamer number one
player on YouTube better than any oh wow
did he pee on the couch it's not let's
throw a fart in his face stupid dad
stupid fart kid I should have never got
that [ __ ] pregnant stupid fart kid how
did we escape then throw a window
probably oh there's the keys of chairs
of course just farted
wait for it dude I'm farting on the keys
what's the problem we got the brass
lucky and another fire in a dead space
but there's more there's more to deal
with here we're gonna have to use our
wits and intellects God another one
excellent we did it
[Music]
captain pay
yes Maya gentlemen with the power of
diabetes control I used to be a simple
elementary school student but then one
day a freak fire accident turned my
diabetes he's a super booing strikes
rule I'm excited that's great well he's
wearing one of those diabetes things I
don't know about this captain diabetes
is made for dangerous but no match for
the kawaii queen thank God
it's an honor to fight on your side sir
oh I wanted to do that side quest okay
give me like cheese and we're gonna find
out oh yeah we're gonna fight Randy I'm
nice let's do this let's go let's dance
let's Rumble uh so there's snow in the
map maybe that will do like a difference
I don't know okay the game works now I
was having difficulties yesterday okay
let's psych him out first
it's so annoying it's extremely annoying
all right now we can block him and
captain diabetes can do some punch of
stamping he has a lot
this one this will make them slower got
a debuff as much as we can boys nice
nice
there it is
done nice heck yeah man captain Davies
was strong maybe I should have gone with
a different class now
damn captain diabetes diabetes can
secure this oh okay we did the sidequest
that I wanted to actually spend time
looking for he just turn out to be
himself how great let me just adjust
this ladder and grab disk I've already
loaded it excellent let's go in here
captain diabetes thank you damn it over
in Kyle's house yes backyard if I
remember correctly I think that's what
we're using yeah yeah
Oh what right okay quiet thank you
hey I'm the main Kauai queen yeah how is
it a shortcut through the oh oh nice oh
there's some fun art let's get it cuz he
collects them right tweek and Craig so
cute
okay I'm not I'm not listening please be
quiet please be quiet okay wait why did
I do this what if we farted on the fence
something happened the fart I thought
maybe the fart would friends tell it
teletransport that's the point of the
fan ah whatever let's go the transition
in between cutscenes and actual gameplay
is so nice you're seeing games I find it
annoying but it's a different place we
go to the town square
oh wow
there is a different place gosh damn man
look at that what is happening what is
this what is submission all right let's
talk to him
what oh don't drink it oh oh oh my god
he could die oh that's so sweet
[Music]
okay we'll go and loot there later
follow captain d2 peppermint hippo you
can't or you say let's see oh wait kids
can just enter another way in somewhere
there we go we can shoot that thing not
the diabete no lay off lay off that ball
juice man it's dangerous you don't know
what's gonna happen
know what oh wow
damn thanks man
this is a weird game that's a weird game
isn't it
let's go nice this what a card and
everyone I don't know
oh whoa there's kind of a [ __ ] why did
I take that gentleman Jews gentlemen
Jews everybody
I missed that of trash can I decide but
whatever oh wow we made it I'm gonna
have to censor so much
why are we here let's have a look
wow that is so hot
there's to be up here oh okay all right
let's pick when I you okay just one more
stripper all right no no are we gonna
have to oh wow oh right yeah no talking
until you finish grinding on our jugs
okay you know what this means
lap dance minigame right
are we farting we're farting son
make it stop please stop
Oh oh my yeah we're gonna we're gonna
[Music]
nice airhorn finish lap dance minigame
completed wow what a what a challenge
really pushing the boundaries with a
penis tattoo yeah yeah classy that's her
name her name is classy
yeah classy with an eye and a little
dick that hangs off the sea which [ __ ]
the L out of the SS I'm no ordinary
stripper from you so stupid my boners
weigh me down Oh music is awesome okay
it seems to work this spell as annoying
as it is it does the trick this could
finish him
nice
[Music]
we're gonna have to burrito up here boys
nice and he's gone I wanted to see his
ultimate but whatever
got'em I love the fights it's really fun
I probably will edit them down like it's
mere old it's the weirdest cleanest
Ellen and Wow gin and tonic we don't
have enough money what we're so poor
find a free gin and tonic find a special
ingredient these guys are drinking
scotch they're all drinking scotch
no one drinking a G&T Minh oh we stole a
gin tonic nice ok we'll probably buy
this special ingredient we can buy his
fat stank demo EP oh why not
oh maybe in here okay let's find the
secret ingredient
after we blow up thank you thank you
buggers ah okay we found one great we
need one more of that maybe in here what
do we got here
oh I see it I see it you go up here you
attack this right and then we walk up
rat [ __ ] everyone very nice
okay cool did it done diddly diddly
let's drink the gin and tink I'm sure he
won't taste any of that goodness G&T
craft this DJ with the crafting app okay
we can do that while we're at it
actually have enough yes yes I think so
what is that his weakness
it was barely a fart hasn't even seen
our potential all right miss DJ here you
go all right it's time for dj''q away
[Music]
goodbye everyone goodbye it's been great
but a man's got to do what a man's got
to do
am i right ladies all right let's go
oh wow this is great Oh
[Music]
nobody's allowed back here yeah get lost
you want to get to her you're gonna have
to go oh my god I'm gonna have to fight
the stripper all right let's do it okay
all right let's begin as always for the
tons
captain diabetes is amazing look at all
that damage put his shield himself
and subbing in from the day shift give
it up how many strippers are there are
illness there okay another one - oh my
god Andy she's beautiful all right we
can you see ultimate now for the first
time damn dog all right let's go oh oh
he's eating all the candy oh my god okay
alright well I'm moving dude
clearly there's a lot of stripping we're
almost by her not anyone oh wow oh wow
oh wow oh oh no oh oh very nice very
nice as you say in Sweden when the meter
fills up spurted will interrupt the
current turn and attack immediately
oh my god Edgar now what are you doing
Oh God I don't have time okay you
wasting my time with glooty oh my god
look at that
puzzle have you seen captain diabetes
I'm just running dude
sugar
[ __ ] oh wow
oh he did it is amazing how you've
already know now captain debut hey
no you fought hard kept to diabetes
it's been an honor fighting by your side
because I Green great stone great Hey Oh
you know what makes my fart super bad
and crafted text me is happening oh yes
of course he hinted adjust any
handcrafted tex-mex gotta be something
extra special into special echoes you
know what to do yeah weed I know I know
I know the foreshadowing I'm staying
role alone eat the ensure eat out press
f to pay respects or X to eat the ensure
either hold l2 and r2 thank God mu L I
am doing it oh my God he's turning into
a Super Saiyan it's super farting all
right they said that as well a fart that
could bend space and time time fart
unlocked
of course it's just like life is strange
now we know where that special ability
way look at the white
you know in life the new life is strange
you can't go back in time anymore it
clearly they borrowed it to SAP pocket
I'll make it what in the world I just
don't get how these people can get high
every day I mean I'm sorry but if you're
sticking a cat's ass in your face you
obviously aren't they sniff cat piss or
something and to get high why don't you
kids just go color on some placemats
oh we're meeting like the mob no we were
busy seeking our watches
no fighting crime and an empty stomach
is very dangerous human catch it's for
your own good
whatever she couldn't have left we would
have seen her go out the front door
laughs and maybe heat in the back okay
you guys check it out call us if you
need help we'll be waiting for you with
our breadsticks
[Music]
oh we all like to [ __ ] what your team
has changed okay
[Music]
ma'am Emma excuse me I want to change
some stuff we have made some alternation
to our outfit my god it looks amazing
oh here's the back room sorry so could
you oh they might fight us no [ __ ] what
in the world all right let's see what
cow can do what do you got cow god damn
boy
nice this is a tough one man
probably a tougher I wasn't prepared at
all it's [ __ ] keep feeling what what
oh we made it we made it somehow
oh nice nice
I'm the new agent my girl let's finish
dears nice that was a really fun battle
I can't really how long that tick but it
was worth it
super fine nice carbohydrate Crusaders
[Music]
what a tough choice
anyway trying to make me feel insecure
Lee told me that my baby's better
happening hello captain diabetes sir it
will be my honor
[Music]
wait sorry what Holt yeah okay and then
what use to find an object with a green
base
[Music]
what in the world oh oh yes but if we
were in a car situation I gotta get
psychic know that you can't forget my
face so dumb
oh my god okay let's go we're still
tracking her
we're so close but I'm gonna have to end
this episode here I'm sorry I'm sorry
but I will see you tomorrow with another
episode thank you guys so much for
watching leaving a like comment and all
that shizzle but this'll really
appreciate you guys love you a long time
scrod fam Brad